european governments are planning for
all energy possibilities what we're
watching is a game of political chicken
between the russians and the eu
with germany being on the sharp end
tuesday morning reuters reported
state-owned gazprom will allow at least
some gas to flow thursday after
maintenance is completed work that
required canada to bend sanctions and
allow turbine parts repaired in montreal
to be returned a controversial move
where did the prime minister's office
where did the cabinet um see a win for
canada in all of this uh there's there's
some uh explanations uh or some
suggestions that a canada did this to
ensure the uh unity of the alliance
that's not the case the prime minister
says it is about unity maintaining the
decision was difficult but correct so
russia will not succeed in either
weaponizing
its energy
or dividing
our allies amongst ourselves we are
focused on being there to support
ukraine disagreement among a group of
high-profile retired generals part of a
new advisory council working to get the
right military equipment to ukraine i'm
in broad agreement with canada's
decision it was a very tough one i'm a
slight bit i think more arsh
on the canadian government decision rick
hillier hopes this doesn't signal allies
easing pressure on russia but he's not
so sure in hindsight it may be seen as a
straw that broke the camel's back
meanwhile a new reality for europeans in
the coming months you're going to see
really high gas and electricity prices
this winter across the eu almost
guaranteed russia's next move still a
mystery abigail beeman global news
ottawa